hey guys this is Luca and I am with the
man can you please introduce yourself
to the audience my name is David I'm The
Man Behind podcast Italiano and I teach
Italian
you teach Italian and you teach Italian
pronunciation and today we want to talk
about pronunciation why it's important
whether whether it is important in
language learning and without further
Ado let's get started
so first question is does it matter to
have a good pronunciation when you speak
a foreign language or you think that the
most important thing is actually to
speak the language no matter how good or
bad your pronunciation is
no it doesn't matter bye okay that's it
at the end of the interview is like 30
seconds we made it there no I I think it
matters I think it's important obviously
I mean it's speaking and using the
language is the most important thing
um but I think it plays a role and I
don't know if you agree with me but I
think it's probably one of the aspects
that's most overlooked about language
learning I don't know if you would agree
with me on that I agree with you I agree
um I think one of the most overlooked
aspects is actually intonation within
within the you know yeah the general
pronunciation thing uh but I think that
in school at least as far as I'm
concerned you're from touring right yes
you're Italian like me uh I've never
heard of intonation pronunciation at
school yes when I was learning English
the problem is that many teachers
actually don't know how to teach
pronunciation oftentimes he does but he
does I I think I do or at least I'm I
know more than most teachers most
teachers
I don't know if I can say most teachers
many teachers at least in public
education in Italy don't even have a
good pronunciation themselves right so
um yeah I think pronunciation is
important for many reasons uh number one
it makes you sound more authoritative it
makes you sound better it makes you
sound more credible to the years of
native speakers and this
is something that just happens it's just
like you know I don't I can't say that
it's either good or bad but it's just a
fact of life that if you sound if you
speak with a good accent people are
going to think better of you right it's
true I think it's true I had a lot of
positive experiences when it comes to
speaking a bunch of languages I think
relatively well when it comes to
pronunciation but you also have very
good pronunciation in the languages that
you speak and I want to ask you is that
important for you so let me rephrase the
question but that's just one of the
reasons yes why pronunciation is
important yes but in your specific case
right I can tell uh because this guy is
a polygote he doesn't just teach Italian
speaks a bunch of other languages every
language you speak has you know you have
a very good pronunciation so my question
is
were you interested in that is that
important for you and do you think that
played a huge role in the acquisition of
such a good pronunciation in various
languages in your specific case I would
say my case it's probably one of the
most fun things to do right from the
start
because I mean you can Master
pronunciation or you can get
pronunciation to a quiet to a very good
level
in relatively in a relatively short time
span you know you don't need years to
make your pronunciation very good like
of course you can improve but like you
can get I think 80 percent of the way
they're
in not that um and like in in not in
years or in a matter of uh months
probably whereas pronunciation and
vocabulary
take years so I think pronunciation if
you know the rules you can get pretty
good in a
relatively short or manageable uh amount
of time frame yeah so in my case I
really like pronunciation because first
of all I think
it makes you sexy it makes you sexy it
makes you um
I don't know it's like for me like
learning a language without
pronunciation just isn't the same it's
like
to me it's like if I were if I were to
be speaking English like this it's like
in my mind I'm speaking Italian just
with the different words and different
grammar construction but it's not the
same like you have to I guess
taste the pronunciation if that makes
sense taste the pronunciation in your
mouth
uh yeah I just I just love the way my my
mouth feels when I'm actually producing
sounds that are different from my own
the ones that I have in my native
language same here and I would add that
to me you you hit the nail on the head
when you said that is just if I spoke
like this this is like I start thinking
in Italian as well I speak English but I
think in Italian well if I speak like
this it's a different matter I speak and
I think in a different way so sounds are
connected and associated in my mind with
a different I wouldn't go so far as to
say different identity but I do feel
different when I speak through different
sounds so for me it's like my my brain
is on another wavelength when I speak
with this uh with this pronunciation
while if I speak English with an Italian
pronunciation it's completely different
and the other thing that was really
interesting for me that that you said is
that you like the way it feels in your
mouth and it's true I just love it the
way it feels when I speak a foreign
language so it's amazing right and the
other thing you said and I want to ask
you one more question about this you
said it doesn't take much time right so
a lot of people think that you have to
deliberately sit down just to learn
pronunciation as a different part of the
language you have to deal with this
training
um
you can do that but don't you think that
also by listening and reading and a
little bit of training you know on top
of that can help and you need that much
time and that much effort to learn the
pronunciation of a foreign language
yeah of course I mean this varies a lot
um it really depends on on many factors
and everybody's uh Journey with
pronunciation is going to differ but I
think
yeah I mean pronunciation is something
that as as I think every skill and
language learning takes uh some you know
passive exposure to the language and
some active practice and I think you we
were talking about deliberate practice I
think you really have to practice
deliberately when learning pronunciation
because uh otherwise it's it's not going
to come out now I mean in in a way it is
going to come out naturally especially
if you're talented and if you have a
good year which I mean I think it takes
it plays a role it plays a role in
acquiring a good pronunciation
definitely does help if you have a good
year and I think I do and I'm sure you
do too but if you don't have that
innate talent I think it doesn't really
matter because you can still improve and
the key here and I think in language
learning too is to try to get better not
try to be perfect try to get better and
try to do what you can in order to
improve and there's always room for
improvement so well said very well said
Okay so let's move on and the other
question is yeah the next question what
are the common struggles specifically
for time but I think this relates to
everybody and for every language what
are the common struggles that people
have when it comes to acquiring
pronunciation so in terms of
psychological terms but also technical
terms like for example what are the most
difficult sounds
for non-native speakers for example
specifically for English for native
English speakers trying to learn Italian
okay for instance okay if you're talking
about uh learning Italian for
anglophones I would say the vowels are
obviously very uh they're not
complicated per se because it's it's not
a huge amount of vowels but still you're
gonna have and this is something that
always happens you have you're gonna
have the interference of English valve
phonemes in Italian so you're going to
add sounds that do not exist in Italian
so
um
for instance many English speakers use
the schwa a lot right in Italian and
they reduce final vowels for instance or
you have unstressed yeah
um
I don't know like karates I think many
people many English speakers could say
like something corrects
maybe they do they are well they do that
sir but they say okay so maybe they
don't quite pronounce the ah in a way
that Italians would for instance and of
course you have uh you know difference
in consonant sounds as well and you have
difference at the phrase level as well
which is also another thing for instance
illusion is a tip is an important
feature of Italian so if I say for
instance
um
ATO I'm not going to say manjat I'm
going to say
and sometimes I can even light the E and
say right it doesn't sound wrong to you
if I say
well yeah because you have connected
speech so you always have to you you
kind of eat words like in English right
but many people say dove
so there's there's yeah there's an extra
syllable that we Allied it's not there
yeah so yeah but and also one thing I
think we didn't mention pronunciation
learning pronunciation is good for
understanding better like to better
understand other people and I think
that's
also true for accents Italian has a lot
of different accents
I don't know if you know many languages
I don't know if there are other
languages that you know where you know
there are so many different accents
Regional accents but in Italian there
are a lot and I think
um maybe you don't want to learn every
single accent and become like Luca who
can do like 20 Accents in Italian but
it's
a good idea to at least get familiar
with uh the main feature of different
accents so that you can understand them
better
so an example of a typical question that
people ask me is should I learn that I
was asked by foreigners should I learn
the accent from Florence should I learn
the accent from Rome what what kind of
accent should you learn when you're a
beginner yeah that's a good question
um I'm a Believer in when it comes to
the case of Italian at least in neutral
pronunciation right what is neutral
pronunciation yeah that's a difficult
question because there is no place in
Italy where neutral pronunciation is
really spoken and neither florist or
Milan or Rome
um it is sort of a construct but is it
is a construct that some people use like
voice actors for instance or people who
use their voice in a professional
setting so and I have by the way I have
a course about that and I have many
videos about that maybe we can link them
below but
um you know it's so if we will sort of
an average of 10 Central Italian
um
pronunciations if you want to you know
make it very general yeah yeah to put it
simply yeah and uh and I think
you know it's it's a good system it's a
good pronunciation to learn because
you're going to be understood perfectly
by everybody
uh and you're gonna you're not gonna
have a regional accent that maybe some
people don't want to have maybe some
people don't want to sound like they're
from Milano they're from Rome
specifically if you want go for it but
if you just want to have a neutral
accent the thing is there is no City
like maybe in other languages where you
can just learn the accent of Paris and
that's sort of the neutral accent of
French because of political and cultural
reason and in Italy we don't have that
but there is a model that it's still
respected and recognized by Italians
themselves as neutral right I would add
that as a beginner it doesn't really
matter because you cannot even tell the
difference between an accent from Roman
and accident from Florence but then yes
there is a standard and if you want to
learn of that that's perfectly fine I
would also add that the foreigners I met
who have a specific accent in Italian
they lived they learned the language
immediately by living directly I don't
know maybe they have a partner from Rome
or Florence they lived right directly in
the environment just where the majority
of the time to listen in that specific
action in that case they get a specific
action but if you're learning at home
and you don't have the chance of living
in country in Italy then it's a
different matter and you can always
listen to this fans podcast because this
action is quite neutral actually I I can
tell you're from the north but I would
say it's a very clean accent that if you
learn is just standard more or less now
I've modified it a little bit in order
to you know neutralize some of the most
Regional some of the more Regional
features I have in my um in my speech
it's not something teachers have to do
but I think it's good also for teachers
to be aware that they might have a
regional accent you know and not many
teachers do if I have to be completely
honest so because maybe you're learning
for someone who comes from a very from a
specific Stadium they have a strong
accent and maybe as a learner you're
picking up those features but you don't
really want to like you're you didn't
set out to do that and so but but you
didn't know that you know your teacher
or your whatever people you're following
had that accent so yeah I try to be as
neutral as possible and but it's also
good it's mandatory in Italian to be
exposed to lots of different accents as
well because can you really say that you
understand Italian if you don't
understand someone from Sicily or from
vanitor from Naples I don't think so so
the bottom line is start with this man
and then you can venture to The
beautiful landscape of the different
diversity of Italian Accents in Italy
okay so very interesting I have two
final questions uh one is about the
psychology of acquiring a different
accent in particular Italian and the
other one is how to actually do this
like if you have any pieces of advice of
like what do you do in practice in order
to improve so let's start with the first
one my question is do you think that
speaking with a native sounding accent
gives you confidence when it comes to
speaking a language I think it totally
does I think it totally does
um
yeah in your case for example how do you
feel when you speak English and you get
complimented of Your Action does it
motivate you to do even like has has
this played a role when you get
compliments from native speakers saying
oh you speak so well it is very
flattering as we were talking about we
were saying yesterday once there was a
guy an american guy who
didn't believe I wasn't American and
asked me for my passport passport he
wanted to see my passport it doesn't
happen that often uh and I think you can
tell that I'm not American
um but yeah of course him you know it's
a it's an ego boost I've got to say
exactly the same thing
I don't know for me I if I managed to
speak well with a good accent I just
feel good when I do so yeah I feel good
and that goes for any language
um the psychological yeah one more thing
I wanted to ask you
do you think that anybody can achieve a
native like native-like pronunciation or
do you think this is just belong this is
just a feature of the few lucky ones who
happen to have a talent for or a knack
for accents I think I think you can get
better everybody can get better for sure
and if you
do certain things you're gonna get
better
I I think it's very hard to get
to a near-native level of pronunciation
and it's almost impossible for most
people of course it depends on a lot of
variables
um there are people who and if we're
talking about people who don't live in
the country of the target language
um I would say it's it's difficult it's
not impossible but it's very difficult
and it shouldn't be the goal you
shouldn't be obsessed with that I think
um because it's it's almost unattainable
in my opinion even like the two of us we
speak very good American English but
there's always going to be Minor Details
that so you can get very close and I
think we have to you know
we have to mention
like I think Talent plays a role like uh
I have to talk about this thing maybe
you won't agree with that I don't know
if you will but I think you know the
people who speak that I met who speak
with very good accents you know they
they
have a a very uh evident ability of
picking up sounds very quickly and so I
think Talent plays a role it doesn't
stop you from trying to it shouldn't
stop you from trying to get better if
you feel like it doesn't quite as easy
it doesn't come as easy to you
but you know I think
um it does play a role like every
everything else in language learning
there's going to be a neonate element
like you might have innately better
memory and or
being innately
better at memorizing uh words for
instance so you have to improve some
people are going to find it easier I
think I think nurture versus nature this
is a the common thing uh not just in
language learning I believe if if I can
share my opinion I believe that it's
your turn it's my channel yeah it's your
interview it's my channel
um I believe 80 percent is hard work and
uh wanting to sound like a native 20 is
Talent so for like the bottom line is
that if you work hard on it and if
you're interested in it you're gonna get
a very good very good pronunciation but
to get to the upper echelons let's say
of a native sounding of a native
sounding accent um a talent or an
inclination towards imitation in general
can can uh can uh can make a difference
this is this is the uh the kind of you
know cover the final stretch
um okay so that's for the psychology the
psychological part of acquiring an
accent what about what is it that you do
to through vaccines to improve your
pronunciation and what is it that your
students do like you know I know that
this is kind of complex but yeah some
very practical tips on what to do every
day to improve so first of all I would
suggest separating sounds from letter so
or phonemes from graphemes if you want
to be really nerdy nerdy about it
because letters are not sounds writing
is a technology that's usually not very
good it depends on the language but you
can't rely on orthography to to
understand how a language is spoken so
sounds are one thing orthography is not
a is a different thing it's not even
enough representation yeah it's
orthography is not language per se or
it's a technology that's used to write
language it's language adjacent if you
will but it's not the language per se so
yeah you have to understand that you
have I think it's good to understand the
concept of phonemes so these sounds that
are discrete categories in a language
that can be meaning and you have to
learn what the sounds what the phonemes
are and how their pronunciation can vary
in other words allophones in linguistic
terms I think it's useful and that's my
opinion to learn the IPA
um not everybody agree I don't think
it's necessary but I think it's useful
because it's something you can do
relatively quickly and if you know many
languages many of the symbols are going
to transfer from one language to the
next so you have to learn like 20 30
symbols it's not and many of them are
going to be similar to their
some Latin letters so it's not
impossible I think it's very useful to
do that
um with what are their other tips
shadowing is a technique that I think
most polyglots use and it's very good
especially for learning intonation and
also I would say doing some active
listening when you when you're
listening to a language
um maybe spend some time actually
paying attention almost like in a
mindful way being mindful
of every single sound feature of every
single detail maybe you can do it you
know five minutes a day you shouldn't do
it for hours on end I think but you
should you should do it
for short stretches of time and then
maybe also try to do some shadowings but
I think it you shouldn't spend too much
time doing that because it might get
boring if I may add one piece of advice
I would say focus on chunks of language
so for example say you're learning
Italian right and you you hear Ali nizio
at the beginning so instead of focusing
on the single Parts alinis is just two
words but you learn
to be to be frank
you learn the entire expression
so maybe when you're shadowing you can
Shadow by using chunks of language this
is what I do for Serbian for example I
learn these Expressions to help me or
connectors or you know
um
so these are all chunks of language then
then you can connect one with one
another like you can and you can start
form sentences and I think this is a way
of you know going about yes because
speech is a flow it's not separate words
it's uh philosophical notes speeches of
flow it is indeed yeah yeah and actually
like being fluent even in the word
fluent of course fluency entails many
different things but if we're talking
about this concept of flowing I think
speech has to flow if you it shouldn't
stop too much and words should be
connected and you have to learn how
words interact and how sounds combine
how you can go from a sound to another
sound for instance yeah don't take
sounds as like single Parts but just see
them as parts of a whole this is a very
important thing that if you learn how to
do it properly with the right training
it can work wonders for you so speaking
of training as we said we hinted at it
uh before you have a course for those
who want to learn Italian right what's
what's the name of this course it's
called phonetic Italian
and I talk about Italian pronunciation
Italian phonetics I give an introduction
to articulatory phonetics and I talk
about all of the Sounds in detail there
are exercises as well I talk about
phrase level uh phenomena that happen in
the language and
um you know the people who've taken the
course so far have really enjoyed it so
fantastic you can find a link in the
various links in the description box in
case you're learning Italian and you're
interested in improving your
pronunciation that video thank you very
much thank you and I'll see you guys
very soon bye from Warsaw bye from now